als erster irdischer flugkörper
überhaupt ist die sonde parker soll
apropos in die atmosphäre der sonne
eingetaucht laut nasa ist das ein echt
zitat monumentaler moment und eine zitat
bemerkenswerte leistung so die us
raumfahrtbehörde und dabei hat sie
bahnbrechende erkenntnis über die
oberfläche geräumt und ist durch eine
gigantische struktur geflogen klicks zum
science sind flugzeuge gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen das ist das erste
mal überhaupt ein irdischer flugkörper
hat es nun geschafft die nasa-sonde
parker soll abdruck ist durch die äußere
atmosphäre der sonne geflogen und hat
damit diesen stern berührt nach den
angaben der us raumfahrtbehörde nasa hat
die sonde dabei in der sogenannten
sonnenkorona die magnetfelder und
partikel untersucht um bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse gewonnen im august vor zwei
jahren 2009/10 war die packers einer
sonder aufgebrochen zu ihrer langen
reise der plan der nasa ist spektakulär
denn die sonde soll der sonnenoberfläche
so nahe kommen wie sonst noch kein
anderes menschen gemachtes objekt
forschungsteams weltweit wollen mit
ihrer hilfe nicht nur das magnetische
feld der sonne untersuchen sondern vor
allem verschiedene rätsel lösen warum
ist diese äußere sonnen atmosphäre
deutlich heißer als ihre oberfläche und
wie werden hier die sonnenwinde auf
einen wert im überschall bereich
beschleunigt und verstoßen so scheinbar
gegen naturgesetze jetzt also der zitat
meilenstein die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler der nasa es bezeichnet
als erste raumsonde überhaupt
überschreitet sie die grenze zur sonnen
atmosphäre statt so der nasa
wissenschafts direktor thomas zerbrochen
das ist ein monumentaler moment für die
sonnen forschung und eine wirklich
bemerkenswerte leistung wie genau ist
der durchflug abgelaufen und welche
rätsel der sonnen forschung können damit
gelöst werden alles zu dem nasa
durchbruch jetzt hier bei pixum science
in future das ist tatsächlich ein
meilenstein der sonnen forschung die
packers dollar pro partie grenze der
solaren coroner durchflogen gemeint ist
damit die obere atmosphäre der sonne
also quasi die äußere schicht der
begriff corona bis lateinisch und
bedeutet so etwas wie kranz oder krone
die korona bildet also wenn man so will
die atmosphäre dem sonnenbrand der
mehrere millionen grad celsius heißer
ist als die oberfläche der sonne in der
korona können bis zu 5,6 millionen grad
celsius herrschen bei 5500 grad liegen
die temperaturen auf der
sonnenoberfläche
doch warum ist das so das ist eines der
größten rätsel der sonnen forschung
überhaupt forschende können sich dass
trotz intensiver forschung immer noch
nicht genau erklären eine weitere
bislang ungelöste frage betrifft die
sonnenwinde die auch den strom und
kommunikationsnetzen auf der erde
gefährlich werden könnten hierbei
handelt es sich um den strom von
protonen elektronen anderen teilchen den
die krone richtung erde schießt doch
diese sonnenwende verstoßen scheinbar
sogar gegen die naturgesetze dazu nicola
fox eine wissenschaftlerin des nasa
sonden projekts der entstehungsort des
sonnenwindes die atmosphäre der sonne
ihre krone muss extrem energiegeladen
seien 300 mal so heiß wie die oberfläche
der sonne das widerspricht naturgesetzen
es sollte keine wärmequelle geben die
heißer wird wenn man sich von ihr act
bewegt dort gibt es irgendeine
zusätzliche energie gegen eine schwarze
mappe der solar wind lässt sich nicht
einfach von der sonne gern nimmt
irgendwie auch ihr magnetfeld mit sich
egal in welche richtung es zeigt wie
stark es ist es eher start im
sonnenlicht bisher weiß man die korona
besteht aus extrem energiereichen gasen
die von der sonne verströmt werden von
der erde aussehen wie sie nur bei einer
totalen sonnenfinsternis und zwar als
strahlenkranz um die sonne fachleute
definieren die grenze der solaren corona
durch den punkt an dem die magnetfelder
der sonne nicht mehr stark genug sind um
die von ihr ausgehenden energiereichen
teilchen ströme festzuhalten
der sonnenwind überschreitet hier die
sogenannte als wen geschwindigkeit
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
meinen damit dass die energie und damit
die geschwindigkeit der teilchen die
bindende energie der solaren
magnetfelder übersteigt doch wo genau
liegt diese außengrenze der so lang eine
frage die bislang ebenfalls
unbeantwortet geblieben war schätzung
zufolge könnte sie zehn bis zwanzig
sonnen radien von der solaren oberfläche
entfernt liegen doch je nach dem
elfjährigen aktivitätszyklus der sonne
könnte ja abstand auch schwanken die
parker soll ab ob wird deswegen im laufe
ihrer sonnen um wohnungen immer weiter
in dieses potenzielle grenzgebiet
einbringen die auswertungen der sonden
daten offenbaren jetzt dass es bereits
am 28 april 2021 so weit war allerdings
konnten die daten erst jetzt ausgewertet
werden demnach hatte die parkas abdruck
bei 18,8 sonnenrad in rund 13 millionen
kilometer über der sonnenoberfläche die
grenze der korona erreicht dazu sagt der
us forscher nur rafi wir sehen belegen
dafür in den messdaten zum magnetfeld
zum sonnen wind und auch optische in den
kamerabildern wir können direkt sehen
wie die raumsonde durch koronare
strukturen fliegt die sonst nur während
einer totalen sonnenfinsternis sichtbar
sind dass die daten erst jetzt
veröffentlicht worden sind hat auch
einen grund nach angaben der nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
liegt das daran dass die daten einige
monate brauchen um zu reden zu gelangen
weitere monate dauert es dann um die
daten auszuwerten fest steht jetzt es
handelte sich um den achten vorbeiflug
an der sonne hierbei tauchte die sonde
mehrmals in die krone ein und verließ
sie wieder und das hat selbst die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
überrascht dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher nur rafi so nah an der sonne
registriert die packers oder punkten
bedingungen in der magnetisch
dominierten schicht der sonnenatmosphäre
die wir nie zuvor untersuchen konnten
wir sehen ein magnetfeld daten sowie in
den sonnenwind datenfunk visuell auf
bildern hinweise darauf
für uns in der korona dürfen insgesamt
drei mal ist sie laut der daten in der
scuola innere eingetaucht und einmal
sogar über fünf stunden hinweg heißt
also im klartext die grenze wurde in der
fachsprache die albin oberfläche der
korona ist nicht rund und überall gleich
weit von der oberfläche entfernt sie
weist lokal senken und spitzen auf genau
das hatten fachleute im vorfeld auch
vermutet dazu sagt der us astrophysiker
justin caspar wir haben erwartet dass
die raumsonde früher oder später
zumindest kurzzeitig die korona
passieren wird aber es ist sehr
aufregend dass wir diesen punkt jetzt
schon erreicht haben zudem gab es eine
weitere überraschung für die vorstellen
die packers ole book hat bei ihrem flug
durch die sonnenatmosphäre nämlich zudem
auch noch einen sogenannten pseudo-
streamer durchquert gigantische
strukturen die quasi aus der sonne
heraus wachsen es handelt sich um die
sichtbaren ausläufer der solaren corona
die gekennzeichnet sind durch das starke
magnetfeld auf engem raum auch das also
eine neue spektakuläre erkenntnis
gewonnen mit der hilfe der packer soll
laut der fachleute war das durchfliegen
des pseudo streams wie der flug in das
auge eines sturms und ihr durch flug
durch die sonnenkorona wird nicht der
letzte gewesen sein auch beim letzten
vorbeiflug im november 2000 21 könnte es
sich nach ansicht der fachleute um ein
flug durch die solare corona gehandelt
haben doch auch hier werden wir uns noch
gedulden müssen ehe die daten auf der
erde zu empfangen sein können denn erst
wenn die raumsonde sich wieder von der
sonne entfernt hat kann die haupt am
tender ausgefahren werden die daten des
aktuellen vorbeiflug sind etwa in diesen
tagen ende dezember 2001 hat sich auf
der erde angekommen und auch von diesen
und weiteren vorbeiflügen erhoffen sich
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sehr viel dazu der
us-forscher justin caspar es ist
wirklich eine wichtige region wenn der
alle möglichen physikalischen prozesse
beginnen umso spannender ist es dass wir
nun diese region erreichen und einige
dieser prozessor phänomene beobachten
können der nächste flug durch die
sonnenkorona steht im januar 2001 hat
sich an also jetzt schon bald dabei
handelt es sich dann um die insgesamt
elfte annäherung an die sonne dann soll
die packers dollar pop sogar nur noch
8,8 sondern radien von der
sonnenoberfläche entfernt sein also tief
in die krone eintauchen möglicherweise
kann dann auch das mysteriöse rätsel um
die so genannten speed specks geklärt
werden die sehr kurzlebigen und abrupte
kehrtwenden der teilchen ströme im
sonnenwind konnten überhaupt erst mit
hilfe der park us-dollar pro offenbart
werden sondern ministerium gelöst
spektakuläre mission der park us-dollar
sondern sorgt für große überraschung
denn der erste flug durch die
sonnenkorona war nicht die erste
überraschung also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren bis dann bleib dran